welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of 2000's
X-Men this franchise is officially
resurrecting to merge with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine joins Deadpool in Marvel's one
film of the Year 2024 so we knew we had
to go back through all 13 of the fox
X-Men films for an X-Men stick stick
rewatch to break down new secrets and
identify what elements of this franchise
in which Kevin feige got his start that
he will deem worthy of bringing back in
Deadpool 3 so every week we're going to
have a fresh in-depth breakdown of each
of these films everything you missed and
everything you need to know and that
includes one or two things no one really
ever talks about with these films now
for any possible plot implications from
this film to Deadpool 3 that I consider
to be too much of a spoiler for anyone
not following the leaks or rumors about
Deadpool 3 I'm going to delay those to a
spoiler section I'm calling the danger
room at the end of the video and to
celebrate this X-Men stick stick rewatch
we are doing a special X-Men themed
merch release which is really the best
way to support new rock stars grab one
of these designs by clicking the link in
the description okay in the opening 20th
Century Fox logo the X lingers a bit on
the Fade to Black they keep this going
throughout the subsequent X-Men movies
and throughout this film there are just
a ton of x's prominently and not so
prominently displayed in scenes from
obvious ones like Charles Xavier's
necktie pin and Aurora Monro pendant
necklace to the way just window frames
fold but I just like that they set this
Easter egg hunt up right here out of the
gate now the reason we're seeing 20th
Century Fox here is that Marvel of
course sold the film rights of the X-Men
to Fox in the late '90s but in 2019
Disney completed an acquisition of Fox's
film and TV properties which would be
why they couldn't out appear in the MCU
but 5 years later why haven't we seen an
X-Men movie in the MCU yet well there's
a specific reason that people avoid
talking about that I'll get to later in
this breakdown but this franchise and
its characters are near and dear to
Marvel head Kevin feige who got his
start in Marvel film making as an
associate producer on this film he
actually began as an assistant to
executive producer Lauren Schuler Donner
one of Hollywood's most accomplished
producers and producing partner and
spouse to the great director Richard
Donner director of 1978 Superman the
superhero movie that Kevin feige always
wanted to recreate with his films what's
interesting though about feige is that
he didn't really grow up as a reader of
comic books he just loved Star Trek and
Star Wars and comic book movies like
Superman but when he was assigned to
this X-Men film in his early 20s he
tasked himself with reading every Marvel
comic he could get his hands on and he
fell in love while director Brian Singer
banned comic books from the set feige
was the go-to comics Guru and Hugh
Jackman later said that he would sneak
over to feige's office to read up on
Wolverine Source material and I just
find that to be an interesting Paradox
that despite feige's reputation as a
Comics nerd he was a late convert to
Marvel lore and he didn't burn out early
into like a defensive gatekeeper like a
lot of guys who grew up reading comics
sometimes do he never really had that
chance to become dissatisfied with where
Comics were going while his tastes
mature in One Direction and Comics pivot
in another direction to appeal to
changing societal interests and so just
as an adult he just kind of fell into
this Trove in his adult adulthood and he
appreciated it for what it was and I
think that specific set of circumstances
what made this movie so authentic to
people who love X-Men and what would
later make the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so successful but in these opening
seconds feig's love of Star Trek must
have delighted this nerd to hear Patrick
Stewart open this film with the
narration as Charles Xavier mutation it
is the key to our Evolution it has
enabled us to evolve from a single cell
organism into the dominant species on
the planet now we are seeing five
subatomic particles swirling leaving
these Trails of Stardust and randomly
colliding as we are seeing a mutant Gene
being activated and the film depicts it
as a cosmic event later on in the third
act they will use the same white tinted
Cosmic radiation to show how mutation
can be artificially recreated but here
in these opening images we swoop down a
spinal column as light illuminates nerve
endings all parts of the body until
swooping back up in Reverse into the
brain which gets locked behind a closing
X door this would be the room that
houses cerebro I think we are beginning
this whole franchise in a moment moment
of meditation with Charles Xavier as he
reflects upon the moment he was in utero
and his mutant Gene was activated
there's actually a specific psychic
battle that Charles fought in this stage
of his life in the comics that Deadpool
3 might bring up but more on that in the
danger room but the XO closing with this
dial lock like a bank vault would go on
to be an iconic image for the X-Men
franchise a symbol of secrecy and
security having to keep these genetic
traits in the closet so to speak
recently in Loki season 2 the blast
stores of the TVA Loom observation deck
were clearly influenced by this design
the next secret behind this door is the
origin of Eric lener future Magneto we
see raindrops in the mud as Jewish
people were marched into aitz in 1944
and we Linger on their dress shoes a
striking symbol for anyone who has
visited the Holocaust Memorial Museum in
Washington DC which includes 4,000 shoes
on display of victims of the Holocaust
taken from them upon their entrance to
camps like these X-Men has always told
the story of bigotry and otherness
Stanley conceived them in the 1960s as a
metaphor for the Civil Rights Movement
these movies in the early OTS were posed
as metaphors for the gay rights movement
and as a victim of the Holocaust Eric
lyncher understands that bigotry on two
fronts young Eric notices the prisoner
tattoos of the prisoners on the other
side of the fence and later on in this
film he will look down at his own tattoo
a constant reminder of Mankind's
capacity for cruelty and intolerance as
Eric is separated from his family and
hears his mother screaming for him he
inadvertently uses his powers forcing
the gates outwards and bending them into
the shape of an ex while for Charles an
x on a door is a symbol of secrecy and
inner meditative illumination X marking
the spot so to speak for Eric lyncher
it's a symbol of pain onto another
origin story in Meridian Mississippi the
not to distant future Marie who will
later take up the moniker of Rogue
played by Anna pacin in this movie
fantasizes about a post high school trip
to Canada which is what leads her there
when she runs away she has a Statue of
Liberty sticker for shadowing the final
battle where she will get her iconic
silver hair streak her boyfriend goes in
for a kiss and his blood vessels bulge
out of his skin as she drains the life
force from his body I love that
uncertain look that pacin gives right
before the kiss as if skin-to-skin
contact might have had this effect on
others for her before just on a smaller
scale in the comics his boyfriend is
identified as Cody in this makeout
session rendered him permanently Kos but
notice how in this movie Magneto and
Rogue are the only two characters for
whom we see origin stories in this movie
not Wolverine not Professor X not Scott
Summers just these two characters
because really secretly this movie is
about these two people gradually getting
closer and closer together as Magneto is
hunting her down to exploit her for his
own agenda Jean Gray testifies before
the US Senate explaining what we just
saw these mutations manifested puberty
and are often triggered by periods of
heightened emotional stress Jean is
dressed in red as she often is in this
movie a little nod to her eventual fiery
dark Phoenix Persona and we meet Senator
Robert Kelly who uses an anti- mutant
stance to further his political career
pushing a mutant registration act he
says I have here a list of names which
evokes the way Senator Joe mcarthy would
produce lists of names of supposed
Communists in the US government in the
1950s Senator Kelly goes on senator
here's a a girl in Illinois who can walk
through walls obviously referring to
Kitty Pride AKA Shadow Cat we will see
her later in this film and in X2 and the
character was recast as Elliot page for
the Last Stand Senator Kelly fearmongers
that the girl could Infiltrate The White
House which is a threat that manifests
in the opening sequence of X2 with
nightcrawlers Senator Kelly says the
American people deserve the right to
know whether their children are going to
school with mutants being taught by
mutants and in the year 2000 this was a
thinly bailed metaphor for the
persecution of LGBT teachers an issue
that sadly keeps coming back up Charles
watching from the gallery turns his head
sensing Magneto's presence Charles is
the mutant Kelly was referring to
obviously who can enter our minds but
chooses not to In This Moment Eric
lyncher is wearing a hat not unlike the
one his father wore in the opening scene
and this walkway isn't like any in the
actual US capital but you know neither
was that Senate room remember this is a
not too distant future this walkway is
actually Roy Thompson Hall a concert
venue in Toronto they're surrounded by
ex's all around them on the Windows as
if to say x jeans are everywhere all
around us and Eric is reflected in the
glass panels of that walkway kind of
like the look of his prison at the end
of the film Charles says mankind has
evolved since then yes into us I love
the shot composition of the scene
Charles's face is illuminated in
sunlight Eric's is in Shadow Charles is
represented often with the ex of his
wheelchair spokes in the foreground
while Eric looks small in the background
the relationship between these two
characters was inspired by the one
between Dr Martin Luther King Jr the
Civil Rights leader who preached
nonviolent resistance and legislation as
opposed to Malcolm X who preferred
change by any means necessary both men
were necessary to further the advances
of the civil rights movement and yes
obviously this is a philosophical debate
that Ryan cougler brought back to its
racial Roots when he was staging the
conflict between tala and kilmonger in
Black Panther Rogue hitchhikes still
Laughlin City a fictional town in
Northern Alberta Canada this truck
driver with a big walrus mustache who
drops her off is George buza the voice
of Beast in X-Men the Animated Series in
a few video games my name is Mr McCoy
this is Laughlin City and we meet Logan
well Hugh Jackman he's not quite as
jacked as he would become in subsequent
X-Men movies but that's part of why we
love him in this movie he's still badass
without being like huge it's crazy to
think that he was relatively unknown
before this film he was an Australian
stage actor recommended for this role by
his friend Russell Crow after Crow
turned the world down and this is just
one of the all-time greatest Marvel hero
introductions he's an animal in a cage
fight as he fights every time he lands a
punch we hear the metal of his
adamantium underneath the skin
clinking there's even a metallic grind
in the sound mix when Logan stretches
his neck ladies and gentlemen yeah I
thought that was his dog tags but no no
that is definitely his neck now the
bartender here is actor Doug Linux who
actually reprises this role for X-Men
the Last Stand in an alternate ending
these bar scenes were filmed inside
goodham and warts distillery in Toronto
Canada which is actually the same
location where they filmed the
Concentration Camp scenes the song
playing in the background is lucenda
Williams's Still I Long for Your Kiss
which is about a heartbroken woman who
still Longs for her Lover's kiss Rogue
Longs for a kiss that she knows she'll
never have the coat that Logan is
wearing here is actually the one he gets
an X-Men Origins Wolverine from the
character Travis it's not really an
Easter egg for this movie it's an Easter
egg for the later movie but you know
continuity now we got to talk about Hugh
Jackman's look here his hair was
fashioned into these pointed wings with
chops jutting down into his thick Scruff
this is really a compromise to maintain
Wolverine's iconic silhouette from the
comics it is frustratingly in most other
instances in this movie visually Brian
Singer in the studio felt that comic
accuracy would not be believable but you
could sense Kevin pige screaming from
the sideline here to at least maintain
the the dog tags and the pointed hair
because for a character to look like the
comic book character in closeup and
silhouette at least with the facial hair
is really at the end of the day the most
important thing so that you know from a
distance or if you like squint your eyes
or if they're in a shadow backlit they
still look like the comic book hero now
the loser in this cage fight pulls a
knife we see Wolverines atam antium
Claus coming out for the first time
since his own knuckle skin is getting
cut here I don't think YouTube will let
us show it Tik Tok definitely plugged a
video I made about this but I love this
close-up of the middle claw extending
delayed slowly while hu Jackman's eyes
staring at the camera in the upper right
it's definitely a practical effect
probably made by leather or latex but
you know it's practical because you see
that middle claw reflected in the metal
of The Claw on the right and seeing
Logan's skin tear miserly reminds us how
painful this is for him as he says later
when they come
out does it hurt every time every time
the bartender pulls a shotgun similar to
the one that he will pull in The Last
Stand alternate ending right before he
says I remember you and Logan I love
this slices through the gun in the
precise spot to make the buck shot spill
out but without clipping the guy's arm
and if you look closely on the severed
end of that Barrel you can see the cap
still in the chamber this move gets
called back in Logan except that time
he's much less precise in his old age
and he cuts the guy's arm off when
slicing through the shotgun now it's
always interesting to me how Logan
retracts his claws because it's never
really quite clear how he does that but
in shots of his X-rays and when Magneto
widens his claws on the train later you
can see little screws on the base of the
claws to suggest that these were screwed
and bolted into his adamantium skeleton
separately so there might be some muscle
operated trigger that slid slides the
claws back in now of course later movies
in this franchise would apply that he
had bone claws but here in this movie
it's just stuff that was surgically
added actually years later in a 2022
episode of She-Hulk they referenced this
moment with a headline on a News website
man with metal claws fights in barbol
but it's the same kind of VFX Easter egg
that eternals Defenders point to to say
that the MCU has referenced himma in the
ocean when it's you know just something
someone threw in there that no one
really saw except people who make and
watch the Youtube videos like this so I
just don't know how much weight it has
in viewers Minds as proof that X-Men
continuity is part of the same universe
as the sacred timeline MCU but for an
awesome theory for how these two
universes could exist together the
YouTube channel Comics explained host
Rob Jefferson had an amazing pitch for
how in the MCU mutants and X-Men once
existed but Professor X brainwashed all
of society to forget mutants and their
past Wars with Humanity but Vision found
out the truth but kept it a secret but
then Thanos snap awakened some of the
mutants and that leading to this current
Saga where all hell could break loose
now I'm recapping the Twitter thread I
read from him but Rob's video and
initial tweet were mysteriously deleted
I don't know maybe Kevin Pike saw it and
was like too close to what we have
planned and he had the prune Rob I'm
sorry if I'm accidentally putting you on
blast I just really love your theory and
I wanted to shout it out so Wolverine
lets Rogue tag along and she asks about
his dog tags which are the standard type
issued by the Canadian military and they
read 458 25243 Wolverine we'll get their
full backstory and Xmen Origins
Wolverine our break down coming week
four going to be a lot of fun his truck
crashes into a f tree and Rogue
Witnesses his regenerative healing
powers this is an attack by Sabertooth
played by professional wrestler Tyler M
and recast as Le of triber for X-Men
Origins storm and cyclops saveing them
from the exploding truck they escape and
we meet toad played by Darth Maul actor
Ray Park after the depiction of toad in
this movie most post 2000 comic
adaptations of toad were drawn to look
like rayart he's seen at first with
goggles on making his eyes appear much
larger like a toad this metal piece that
he is spray painting here is the piece
of the Statue of Liberty that they later
used to hide Magneto's conversion device
now these metal balls on Magneto's
Newton's Cradle aren't supported by
strings he's just using his powers to
move them but I like you to think about
the amount of concentration required for
Magneto to give into gravity just enough
to replicate The Swinging motion and by
the way for a movie so concerned with
growed realism when it comes to the
costumes the production obviously didn't
mind going full 9s Batman when it comes
to Magneto's Brotherhood of mutants
Island Lair with sets like this I don't
think we would have minded yellow and
blue spandex Magneto says I have made
the first
move that is all I know as we will see
in the final scene this is all one big
game of chess between Eric and Charles
Logan Springs awake frightening Jean
Gray and we are in the X-Mansion
basement with its shiny blue and gray
surfaces and its ex doors looking just
as it does when it's recreated for the
Marvel's post-credit scene Charles
telepathically directs Wolverine to the
elevator and through the ground floor of
the Mansion indeed this is a chess match
Charles is moving his pieces around the
board as much as Eric lenter is Logan
enters Charles's office where he's
teaching a smaller class that includes a
few familiar young mutants that don't
get called out by their monikers in this
film and most of them get recast for
sequels but there is Shadow cat kitty
Pride she's the one who runs through the
door Iceman Bobby Drake that's Shan
ashmore's character this movie is pyro
we'll talk about him later marage
Danielle Moonstar who later gets played
by Blue hunt in 2020s the New Mutants
and this movie's Jubilee on the far left
and take a look at that chalk for
Charles has drawn some diagrams about
the nature of perception and the way
light reflects off objects now I used to
think that this was a visual KN of the
way cyclop will angle his optic blast in
the final battle like refracting it
through his lens at an angle like that
but the deeper detail is actually way
more interesting as Charles assigns the
essays listen closely I'd like your
definitions weak and strong anthropic
principles on my desk on Wednesday he
says he wants them to write about weak
and strong anthropic principles so what
does that mean the anthropic principle
basically says that you can only take
into account things you are able to see
as opposed to what you're unable to see
because what you're unable to see will
bias your opinion of that thing because
you're not basing it off of any kind of
objective perception so strong versus
weak the weak anthropic principle states
that you observe the universe as having
the right conditions for you to exist
because if it had different conditions
you would not exist to observe that the
strong anthropic principle states that
either there are an infinite number of
universes or our univers is infinitely
large with slightly different parameters
SL conditions and laws of physics and
human observers are only present to
observe where the conditions of this
universe permit them to exist so the
weak principle is actually assumed to be
correct but when it comes to the world
of movies with things like the
Multiverse Saga in which the MCU is
merging with an alternate X-Men Universe
movies definitely use the strong
principle so all the way back back here
24 years ago in the year 2000 Charles
Xavier is acknowledging the existence of
the Multiverse which makes it really
cool in the post-credit scene of the
Marvels when Beast indicates that
Charles asked for an update about a
multiversal traveler who came into this
universe from a rift this whole time
that we've seen him this guy is thinking
about the Multiverse Charles formerly
introduces Logan to Scott Summers
Cyclops played by James Marsden and
Aurora Monroe storm played by Hal Berry
now Hal Barry uses a Kenyan accent here
that she will drop in subsequent films
do you know what happens to a toad when
it's struck by lightning not a school
for people like us but we can be safe
both characters actually had scripted
scenes that were cut from the film
Aurora was accidentally going to destroy
her hometown in Kenya with her powers
Scott we were going to see destroying
his high school bathroom these two
scenes were not shot for the film but
Scott Orin was obviously eventually seen
in X-Men apocalypse when he's played by
Tai Sheridan and I think it says
something about how good this movie was
in which pretty much all the leads in
the cast you could see being a-lister
stars in movies today Hugh Jackman James
Marsen haly Barry Patrick Stewart Ian
hel and a pacin Sean Ashmore fam Jans
Rebecca raain like these people just
didn't disappear from Hollywood now
Logan tells them that he doesn't need
medical attention and Charles is like
yes of course because he knows that part
of Logan's abilities is rapid healing
now Scott holds out his hand to shake
Logan's but it's denied and I just love
that we see that animosity right off the
bat between these two characters because
it just wouldn't feel right to have an
X-Men movie where these two were like
best friends and I just noticed a really
fun detail here when Jean Gray passes by
Logan totally checks her out and Scott
notices this you could see him turning
his head like dude bro Logan hates that
they all have nicknames and he tells
Charles what do they call you Wheels
which is actually an adlet from Hugh
Jackman the original script had him
saying what do they call you baldy and
remember the Burger King kids club did
have a member in a wheelchair whose
nickname was Wheels ah the '90s folks
but I like that this movie doesn't shy
away from Charles calling them storm and
cyclops and Magneto like the MCU would
do away with superhero monikers at least
in the early phases and I just think
it's time they came back it's what I'm
most looking forward to from The multier
Saga and the mutant Saga during
Charles's monologue about the school we
get a quick appearance by this character
who's sketching by the pond this is
actually Peter Rasputin AKA Colossus
Donald McKinnon plays him here Daniel
Cudmore will play him in X2 we see a kid
cheating at basketball by using his
teleportation Powers but obviously this
isn't Nightcrawler another kid shouts at
him hey no powers and we're seeing just
a core tenant of Xavier school is to
teach young mutants to hone their powers
but to avoid using them to cut corners
and I believe this kid with glasses is
the same kid with glasses who will later
look out the window and see the jet
flying out of the basketball court
thinking wow I could have accidentally
teleported down into a jet basement and
we see storm lecturing about the Roman
Empire see Hollywood is to blame for men
thinking about the Roman Empire at least
once per day now we only see the
chalkboard here in this scene with Roman
Empire written on it and also emperor
Constantine but in a deleted scene her
lecture goes into more detail the Roman
Empire for centuries they persecuted and
ostracized the Christians then almost
overnight their religion Rose to become
the dominant faith of the Empire does
anyone know what suddenly caused the
Christians to become accepted Emperor
became Christian exactly right emperor
Constantine and his ruling class all
converted she's referring to a
transitional period in which the
persecuted Christians of Rome grew in
number and converted Constantine in
order to flip Rome's political and
social structure to their favor and
Christianity of course would go on to
dominate The Western World obviously
this is very similar to Magneto's plan
to convert Senator Kelly and then all
the world leaders in New York into
muttin so that that PR mutant sentiment
will trickle down through society and I
just like how in the sequence by paying
attention to the chalkboards of Aurora
and Charles in a way the whole Final Act
of the film is set up if you're looking
to ring in the New Year by ringing in a
new you revamping your daily hygiene
routine is the best place to start and
geology is here to help your New Year's
resolutions with new Skin Care Solutions
geology is a 29 time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recognized in
men's health opra daily hype Beast
birdie Esquire and GQ G products use
just like a handful of powerful proven
ingredients that have been trusted by
dermatologists for decades geology can
help you fight acne reduce oiless
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging I mean is it
really a new year if you don't age I
don't think so if you don't know where
to start geology can create a simple and
effective skincare or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30-second quiz right now if you
use code new rockstars 100 gey will give
you 100% off their award-winning
skincare trial set you'll also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30% off
one skin hair or body product when you
add it to to your trial so 100% off plus
an additional 30% off hope you save some
champagne because this is a deal worth
celebrating click the link in the
description or go to geol log. i/
Rockstar 100 to get started a student
named John tries to impress Rogue by
making a ball of fire which Bobby then
freezes Aaron Stanford were going to
play Pyro and X2 and X in The Last Stand
but an actor named Alex Burton plays him
here Burton was a young day player who
worked with a few of Brian Singer
Associates at De Digital entertainment
Network which was a precursor to YouTube
that Brian Singer was affiliated with
despite having no credits Burton was
flown from LA to Toronto to play this
role and the role ended up being cut
down in the final version of the movie
but this takes a dark turn here he sued
three of Brian singer's Associates
claiming that he was sexually assaulted
and held against his will this lawsuit
was joined by two other former Den
employees and they were awarded $6
million but it was never paid Burton
changed his name and never appeared in
another film anytime I watch this movie
I see this guy and his eraser just
really bums me out but it's important to
talk about because the dark shadow Brian
Singer and his associates cast over this
film in the whole film industry
everybody who enabled them is something
that we can never forget just spent some
time Googling Brian Singer there are so
many accounts over the years of sexual
assault intimidation all kinds of
horrible things I broke down in
investigation that Marvel's X-Men delays
might be due to Legacy producers like
Brian Singer contractually obligated to
payouts and credits for any future films
with quote X-Men in the title that is
For Better or Worse how this industry
works so I just think we cannot sweep
this under the rug it's continuing to
plague Hollywood in all kinds of ways
it's okay to still like this movie and
appreciate the good things about it but
there is always more to the story that
we cannot forget so Shan Ashmore plays
Bobby AKA Iceman here after playing Jake
in the short live Nickelodeon anamorph
series he will go on to play Lamplighter
in the boys a character who has pyro
Powers his twin brother Aaron Ashmore
actually played Jimmy Olson in
Smallville Senator Kelly's motorcade
passes signs reading mutants are Killers
Human Rights protect our children and
also this one send the mutants to the
Moon forever now the moon in Marvel Lord
is the home to the Inhumans which was
actually created by Marvel in order to
get around the X-Men film rights issues
like you may remember in the 2010s
Marvel CEO Ike prom was like pushing
Inhumans and humans and even made Kamala
Khan an inhuman even though they wanted
to make her a mutant so that they could
make film adaptations out of the
Inhumans and not mutants and since all
of these are now Under the Disney
umbrella that's why they made kamalak
Khan a mutant in M Marvel also we should
point out in the comics the X-Men also
set up a lunar compound near the blue
area of the moon now Senator Kelly's Aid
is Henry gy which is the name of a big
character from Marvel Comics someone who
goes up against the Avengers even but
Magneto later reveals that Mystique has
been playing the long game Mr gy has
been dead for some time Senator and in
the film's final minutes if you listen
closely there's a news report that
explains what happened to the real gy in
a related story the body of Senator
Robert Kelly's longtime Aid Henry gy was
found today carner's reports seem to
indicate that gy was mauled by a bear
mauled by a bear implies that this was
probably saber-tooth's doing Henry is
where in a blue and yellow tie and when
we see him in the background behind
Kelly a blue lens flare reflects off his
Bas in the sunlight setting up this
transition to the Blue skinn yelloweyed
Mystique played by Rebecca
[Music]
Roma composer Michael Cayman used a
cello for mystique's theme for its
fierceness and eroticism Han Zimmer and
Tina guo later applied the same
principle using the electric cello over
the iconic Wonder Woman theme I got to
say the Mystique shape shifting in this
movie holds up despite her skin you know
looking a bit rubbery smooth like
PlayStation quality if you pause on it
but the motion of it looks great because
they decided to add these scales or
feather-like pieces they're about 3 in
long and they fold and unfold so it kind
of looks like a reptile or a fish
shiting in the light so that their
scales catch the Light differently or
maybe a bird ruffling their feathers
compare that to the transition of the
Scrolls in the MCU or even the Shar in
dark Phoenix where they try to show the
shape shifting on a more granular level
to make it more smooth and Sleek but by
by doing that they just make it more
subtle and it's less of a spectacle but
I point this out because VFX technology
getting better and better and more
refined doesn't always make it look
cooler to viewers sometimes the old way
is better genan gray examines Wolverine
giving him an X-Ray Scan we learn about
his healing powers and his adamantium
skeleton the X-ray if you look closely
implies that the claws and sheaths were
actually added to his exoskeleton as
opposed to how in later films Logan had
bone claws that Weapon X grafted the
adamantium 2o and I like how the X-ray
of his skull shows the adamanian
pleating in a very specific pattern
which I think might be this film's of
explaining why Logan's hair points that
specific way Charles says
experimentation on
mutants it's not unheard of them but
I've never seen anything like this
before now later on in nextmen first
class we see a younger Charles and a
younger Eric briefly encountering Logan
in the early 60s leading to one of the
all-time best cameos go yourself but how
much Charles actually knows about him
here at this point is just unclear
because when they made this movie they
didn't know that like 11 years later
Matthew Bond was going to be doing that
scene Magneto's machine used powers to
harness this goofy CGI light to
irradiate the whole compound that
recalls the light that we saw on the
swirling particles in the opening
imagery now if Marvel Studios ever
wanted to they could use this as a kind
of predicate to say Cosmic radiation can
turn people into mutants or activate a
mutant Gene in any dormant mutants that
way that could tie in thanos's snap that
released a universe-wide blast of cosmic
radiation as a way to create an MCU
mutant Awakening while flirting Gan gray
reads Logan's mind and she sees flashes
of the weapon x program and everything
that William Striker did to Logan and I
like how back in that memory Logan's
eyes open in that tank as if back in
that moment in the 80s he sensed Jean
looking into his mind I bring this up
because Days of Future Past establishes
the existence in this X-Men continuity
of consciousness-based time travel in
which Kitty Pride can project one's
Consciousness into the body of their
past selves so if Kitty could do that
why not the Future Phoenix now I'm not
saying the 2000 film intended this
moment to be that but you know I just
like to think that in my head Canon it
could be possible but we can also
interpret this moment as Jean Awakening
Wolverine's trauma for him because it's
not like he's spent the First Act of
this movie actively thinking about it it
could have been buried in his
subconscious maybe even the Phoenix
force is drawing Wolverine back into the
darkness it just didn't seem like Logan
seemed to be vividly haunted by these
memories until this moment when Jean
read it in his mind so that's why later
this same night he returns through his
memories to that alkal Lake lab where
observers are passing glasses of
champagne I like this detail because it
tells us that he was awake for the
entire procedure Wolverine stabs Rogue
and she borrows his regenerative powers
to heal the way pacin plays it is just
so breath and shocking we forget that
she has this power and can heal herself
I remember as a kid watching the scene
being like oh she's dead and afterwards
she tells storm it was an accident I
like that it could apply both to what
she did grabbing his face and what he
did to her like she's defending Logan in
this moment now I might be overthinking
this but if you look at the big picture
of the plot here it really is Rogue who
Magneto is targeting so on a cosmic
level Logan was unconsciously following
a soldier's instinct to take away the
one weapon Magneto would need I know
Logan didn't want to stab this girl that
he's trying to protect but this movie is
all about sacrifice and removing pieces
off the chess board Magneto struts out
to Senator Kelly cell on a walkway that
he forms out of this metallic plates
that fly up into place right before he
steps on them the prison that he will be
contained within at the end of the film
will use the same kind of collapsible
walkway just made out of plastic Senator
Kelly has been transformed into a mutant
with jellyfish-like flesh and he emerges
naked on a beach passing this hot dog
vendor a non-speaking Stanley Cameo this
is actually his first appearance in a
Marvel movie after appearing in many
Marvel TV shows and having his cameo in
blade cut he also obviously had a cameo
in 19 1995 small rats but that's just
you know a cool movie not necessarily a
Marvel movie and also this guy in the
plaid shirt on the beach is the director
Gary Gard the director of the 1987
Masters of the Universe film and like
Brian Singer has his own list of sexual
assault allegations I know I know guys
now at the start of this scene Bobby
shames Rogue for using her powers and
tells her to leave the school and never
come back but yellow eyes it's Mystique
this is the first of many instances in
this franchise when Mystique will
impersonate others but then flash her
yellow eyes as kind of a wink to camera
even though it would risk exposing her
masquerade to anyone nearby who just
happens to be watching this person it's
a very silly thing but you know it's
just kind of a fun wink that these
movies always do Charles takes them into
cerebro in the door scans his eye giving
us another X Reflection In His pupil now
when he uses cerebro it's always
interesting to me to see how many
mutants he passes through and how most
of them are middleaged like all of them
are older than the students and the
teachers at Xavier school it's just a
reminder that many mutants in this world
have already been living in the shadows
for several generations and might not
even be aware that they possess the
mutant Gene Wolverine finds Rogue on the
train and she says this really
interesting line the first boy I ever
kissed ended up in a com for 3 weeks I
can still feel him inside my head and
it's the same with you I can still feel
him inside my head such an interesting
idea right like when Rogue absorbs
someone's life force she stores a small
part of them inside of her mind it's
kind of like how the mutant legion's
Powers work he stores a whole Community
a whole Legion of identities or altars
inside of his mind now at this train
station this little boy Smiles up at
Cyclops unlike the a similar sweet
moment in Captain America Winter Soldier
when the boy recognizes C in the museum
this kid's mom pulls her son away from
that scary mutant this moment actually
wasn't initially scripted the kid that
they had on set was just a huge X-Men
fan and wouldn't stop grinning up at
James Marsden who during one take looked
down and smiled back at the kid and they
ended up keeping it in the movie
Sabertooth chokes storm while toad
snatches cyclops's eyepiece so that he
blows a hole in the roof that storm is
able to use to fire a bolt of lightning
at Sabertooth toad tells him to stop
playing around but it was really Toad's
move that gave storm access to the sky
though later I like the detail that toad
is wearing cyclops's eyepiece on his
head kind of like a new pair of
sunglasses I suppose he was just jealous
of saber-tooth wearing Wolverine's dog
tags as a tropy and one one of his own
Magneto peels open the train car and for
the first time in this film he floats in
with this movie's version of a super
villain attire cape and psionic blocking
helmet and because he is not initially
lit he's just lit from behind again we
see an example of how the silhouette is
the most important thing you just have
to have that helmet Magneto widens
Wolverine's claws which always felt so
painful to me even though I don't have
adamantium claws I can just feel that
that pain of his knuckles and Magneto
drops this film's great midpoint twist
what the hell do you want with me you
what F whoever said I wanted you and he
flings Logan back through the car and I
love the little detail of all the taller
passengers ducking down in their seats
so that they don't get decapitated by
these claws Magneto pulls the guns out
of the cops hands and aims them back at
them this Trope of using powers to turn
cops against one another redirect their
guns it's something that we see in
superhero shows like Jessica Jones wav
Vision gen B slew of others and it's
actually Magneto's daughter from the
comics Wanda maxmo who did it but in all
these this one might be the most wild
because Magneto actually fires one of
the guns and he lets that bullet slowly
screw into the cop's forehead as he
screams in pain it just demonstrates
that Magneto isn't afraid to pull the
trigger and there are far more creative
and devastating things that Magneto can
do with a single bullet like he doesn't
need a full Armory of guns just a single
bullet that he could yaka arrow through
everyone's heads and kill them Eric
knows that Charles's weakness is that he
isn't willing to kill him or let
innocent people die and he calls his
bluff giving Eric the upper hand this
helmet obviously blocks Charles's Powers
which we find out in first class was
actually something he got from Sebastian
Shaw Senator Kelly shows up at the
X-Mansion but his body is rejecting the
mutation and he bursts like a water
balloon with a disgusting squelching
noise this is what would actually happen
to all the normal humans at Magneto
tried to eradiate into mutants if he was
successful a lot of world diplomats
homes would just get flood damage on
Liberty Island DB Sweeny cameos as it's
waving Park guard he was actually one of
the actors considered for the role of
Cyclops there's also cameos from Tom
Danto the film's co-writer and executive
producer and later on the film's other
co-writer David heer plays the guard who
finds Mystique in Disguise and says hey
this one's alive the X-Men sued up I
actually go outside and these things
what would you prefer yellow spandex
they would have been totally fine
wearing blue and yellow Spandex and
actually the first time the actors wore
these leather suits on set they had a
hell of a time moving in them and just
so them hopping over the ledge on
Liberty Island was a real challenge we
saw variations of the comics and
animated series blue and gold uniforms
in X-Men first Class but Deadpool 3 will
finally give us Wolverine's yellow suit
in live action Wolverine sets off the
metal detector and hilariously flips off
scott using only his middle adamm claw
right behind Scott you can see Mystique
hiding in plain sight as the smaller
Statue of Liberty before we get the
closeup of the eyes turning yellow and
then after Wolverine disappears behind a
column there's a really subtle visual
detail in the background where after he
goes off on his own you can see the
exact moment that Mystique behind a
different column shape shifts into
Wolverine when her arm juts Out of the
Shadows right before she as Wolverine
approaches the others to try to trick
them so Wolverine and fake Wolverine
fight and the real one gains the upper
hand because his adamantium claws are
real and can slice through the copies so
Mystique as Wolverine screams because
they are really part of her flesh I love
that Hugh Jackman had to react the way
Mystique would have to that pain there's
another solid metallic ping when mying
kicks his
gut but I love that the tables turn when
Mystique reverts to her natural form
she's a far more comfortable fighter
against Logan that way actually KIU Quan
from everything everywh at once and in
Loki season 2 Short Round from Indiana
Jones in the Temple of Doom was one of
the stunt coordinators on this film
footage of him helping with the scene
recently resurfaced much to everyone's
Delight now it's both awesome that he
worked in this movie and kind of a
bummer because throughout the '90s he
struggled to get acting roles he was
really typ cast but he was able to still
be part of some of our favorite films
and the fact that finally 20 years later
Quan was one of the stars of lowy season
2 made his squer trajectory even more
interesting so as toad Ray Park shows
off his amazing fighting skills and
Twirls his pipe at one point like a
staff obviously a self homage to his
work as Darth Maul and then there is
this infamously cringey moment do you
know what happens to a toad when it's
struck by
lightning the same thing that happens to
everything else but I always love
singling out this line because there's
actually a holdover line from an earlier
script that was written by Jos Weeden
the punchline wasn't meant to be
delivered dramatically but rather it was
just kind of a shrug like you know a
joke that Weeden would write for Buffy
the Vampire Slayer but I just find this
to be an interesting Relic from Marvel's
early years because obviously Weeden
would be a huge part of the language and
tone and humor of the MCU with 2012's
Avengers and you could totally imagine
like Tony Stark saying this as Thor was
powering up Muir but you know storm
isn't the character that you give these
kind of jokes to she's always the one
who's screaming at the sky bellowing
speaking in heightened dialogue and
she's always just very sincere that's
what we love about storm so I think this
miscue is important to point out and
it's clearly going to be something
everyone involved with these movies in
the future Marvel Cinema will learn from
when to make jokes and when to be
sincere but Wolverine isn't fooled by
fake storm and he stabs her causing her
to morph back into Mystique I like this
moment she's cycling through different
features as her ability goes out of
control Storm's white eyes shift to
mystique's yellow eyes Storm's hand
turns into Wolverines adamantium claws
which retract back into Mystique skin
and we know that that hurts every time
so that must have hurt her skin to do
that and then she finally collapses now
we get the only other exchange to
survive from the jot Sweden draft hey
hey it's me prove it you're a
dick okay up in the head of Statue
liberty Magneto pins the team against
the metal and when Magneto flies and
lifts rogue's handcuffs notice how the
VFX artists added these little wave
effects so that we can see his powers in
action I suppose they just didn't want
it to look like Magneto can just fly
like Superman can he's just using
magnetism to lift himself it's fun to
watch a final battle of a Marvel movie
take place on the Statue of Liberty
because years later Spider-Man no way
home would do the same thing it's just a
fun set piece Wolverine frees himself by
stabbing his own chest with his claws
and he fites Sabertooth on the crown and
he swings around the spike in a move
that Marvel would later use for black
panther Wolverine nearly Falls but he
catches up with saber-tooth before he
tries to kill storm and he says hey bum
I'm not finished with you yet bub that's
just what wolverine calls people and I
love that they gave him this line in
this movie because those little details
David hater and Kevin feige just knew
needed to be part of Wolverine in this
movie Magneto has activated his machine
using Rogue and they debate how to stop
it the Rings are moving too fast just
shoot it I'll kill her storm can you get
me up there I can't control it like that
you can fly right over the torch and let
me go I totally appreciate Cyclops
leadership skills in this first film
they kind of got away from that in
future films but Logan volunteering is
also his way of trumping it like he's
basically saying I'm heavier than you
bub which would make him more stabilized
in the strong winds I think also Logan
wants Jean's telekinetic grip on his ass
not Scott despite this Wolverine nearly
wipes out giving Rogue her signature
Silver Streak in her hair which if you
think about it is rogue's way of keeping
a piece of Magneto inside of her and
Scott still takes command of the
situation and takes his clear shot at
Magneto when he gets one Wolverine's
most heroic act then is not just clawing
through everything it's lending more of
his regenerative powers to revive Rogue
so in the epilog of the movie Charles
tells Logan about an abandoned military
compound at Alkali Lake in the Canadian
Rockies so Logan steals the motorcycle
again and heads off to investigate
Mystique takes over Senator Kelly's
identity and publicly backs down for the
mutant registration act hilariously they
pause a broadcast and mystique's yellow
eyes are revealed in the pause screen so
I guess just like the uding any footage
of Mystique would reveal her real
identity but also notice that he's
wearing a yellow and blue tie which is
an inverse of the one Mystique wore as
his Aid Henry we end with Magneto in his
metal-free prison made out of glass and
plastic in this old man chess match with
Charles did you actually foreshadow some
of the events of the films that come
after doesn't it ever wake you in the
middle of the night the feeling that
someday they will pass that foolish law
come for you and your children I feel a
great swell of pity for the poor soul
who comes to that school looking for
trouble Xmen apocalypse will end by
referencing this same exchange doesn't
it ever wake you up in the middle of the
night the feeling that one day they'll
come for you and your children I feel a
great swell of pity for the poor soul
that comes to my school looking for
trouble now years later us Grandmaster
Robert Hess actually analyzed Charles
and Eric's specific moves in the endgame
of this chess match for the 538 website
and the strategies and tactics they're
using in their moves actually reflect
their ideologies so Charles is
represented as the character with black
pieces Eric is represented as a
character with white pieces and notice
how Charles is down a queen in several
other pieces but he wins by being hyper
aggressive he forces a Checkmate in just
four moves and he relies mostly on his
pawns this reflects the way especially
in future films Charles is more willing
than Eric to sacrif sacrifice the
mutants on his side and he does it in a
way that's not always so Noble sacrifice
will be a key theme in this franchise
and notice how earlier in this movie
Cyclops was totally willing to risk
sacrificing Rogue and Logan to take out
Magneto and Gan gray moments after that
catches her breath as if some greater
power deep and cider is telling her that
she may be the next one who has to say
when I make my move the queen will take
me and then you're free to check the
king Logan it's not you that's got to go
on I know it not me not Scott you
okay I'm getting away from that cringy
moment to the danger room where we're
going to discuss some possible Deadpool
3 spoilers so if you don't want to think
about Deadpool 3 you're welcome to stop
watching this video okay first detail
the 20th Century Fox logo what a fun
image to open this movie with because it
is the iconic image from all X-men
movies and Deadpool 3 seems to be
bringing it back as a literal setpiece a
crumbling version of this studio logo in
a voides scrapyard that Deadpool and
Wolverine are going to fight on top of
okay let's talk about Charles's psychic
battle as a baby later Comics would
establish that Charles had a twin sister
in the womb Cassandra Nova whom baby
Charles would battle and defeat with the
psychic blast but Cassandra would
survive and later come back to haunt him
Cassandra Nova is rumored to be the role
and aorin is playing a Deadpool 3 we
could be seeing Charles reflecting back
on that baby battle here in the opening
seconds of X-Men 2000 and then again
saber-tooth played by Tyler m in this
movie actually some set imagery shows
that Tyler M's version of this character
will return in Deadpool 3 and perhaps
get decapitated so if he shows up in
Deadpool 3 it's great to see him back in
this movie from 2000 okay that covers
everything from the first X-Men film and
by the end of the series I will rank
every single one of these 13 movies in
quality but I can say this movie holds
up it's a lot of fun and the success of
this movie and the success of Blade from
1998 would set the stage for every
Marvel movie that would come after it if
those movies were not successful we
would not have a Sam Ramy spiderverse we
would not have an MCU so next week will
be our breakdown of the sequel to this
film X2 X-Men United from 2003 a huge
thanks to G aito for her help writing
breakdown you can support new rock stars
with some X-Men inspired merch website
in the description follow me on on all
social platforms at eaos And subscribe
to all three channels of the new
rockstars Network thanks for watching
I'll see you next week Snick stick
bye